all right well good to see you everyone
hope you've enjoyed the conference so
far
i enjoyed having a lunch yesterday with
maxine
which was so big i i couldn't
stay awake in the afternoon i had to
talk right at the end of the day so
today
i decided to make sure i didn't have
breakfast with maxine
came to this talk fresh so it's going to
be a bit easier than yesterday i'll be
talking about domain driven design and
team topologies if you've not heard of
those things before that's totally fine
it's all beginner content really um
and if you know i know a lot of the
talks here are more technical focused if
if you come along for this talk to check
it out and you feel like it's you know
it's not your cup of tea and you want to
leave totally fine
so i'll tell you about my cup of tea the
kind of thing i do for work got an
example here this was my first
experience of doing some in-person stuff
after the pandemic
uh it was in september last year 2021
yep
timelines are a bit fuzzy these days
forgetting what which things happen in
which year
some holiday photos at the top right
hand corner
so basically this company they were
getting together for the first time
after the pandemic a lot of people seen
each other in person and they invited me
to join them for the day to do some
event storming
it was on a farm
well they told me it was in berlin
i looked at the postcode i'm like
that's
that's the kind of thing london would do
when they name an airport that's not a
london airport that's like 100 miles
away from london this was like
50 miles north of berlin on a farm
basically
so it's pretty cool and this this room
here
was the yoga room
on an old farm actually as soon as you
walked in that room you could smell
um
it was a nice smell it's a nice
you know organic wood smell like the old
wood i actually really like the smells
of wood so it was
you know it was great for me um
and so basically we had a whole whole
bunch of people from the company there
involved in this workshop we had
we had like products um head of product
we had a bunch of developers and testers
i think there were ux people there too
we had customer success people who are
actually going out
um helping their
um
their customers their users to use the
product i don't want to give too much
worry about the company
um we had one from accounting there
and we also had the ceo there now this
company was really interesting because
the ceo
he's worked in some big companies
and he's he's trying to
build this startup inside a larger
company
and he wants
his approaches
he really wants the teams to be more
empowered to own the products themselves
he doesn't want to become he kept
calling it a big company
um
so you know the idea was get people
together and we'll do some event
storming we'll
put together their business and how it
works with all of these different people
and we'll see what happens
actually was it was pretty amazing it
reminded me after
um
a lot of months at home during the
pandemic
how how good it can be to get a whole
group of people together in person and
to do some event storming
and
there are a bunch of takeaways from this
day i would say
[Music]
the the thing that stood out to me
was
the conversations between different the
different people especially the customer
success people you know who actually
went out to like warehouses and physical
places
to meet their users
and they were bringing that insight back
into the workshop as we mapped out this
process and the developers were like oh
i didn't realize that oh
i didn't realize the system worked that
way so a lot of crush pollination was
going on and one of the one of the big
things we realized is
um right at the start of the timeline so
with event storming we map out the
business as a timeline
right at the start of the timeline
they were
they were receiving some data and they
had to process that data and clean it up
and make it usable later in the process
but that cleaning up process wasn't 100
successful
and the team
the team working on that were
responsible for that area of cleaning up
the data that data flowed all the way
through the business
affected all of the other teams
and you know it's something something
that happened at the start has an impact
all the way through the business on all
the other teams because the data wasn't
um
i wish i could say more about this but i
don't want to give too many details but
because the data
wasn't fully cleaned up as it went
through the process
um it was having an impact on the users
it was giving them bad information and
so these users didn't want to use the
application and so
downstream the company had to build all
of these incentives and reports
to try and encourage the users please
use the application because
when the user doesn't use the
application um
so someone who's receiving a parcel i
can give a bit away they won't mind um
so someone who receives a parcel will
get um
we'll get like a time slot your parcel
is coming between 11am and midday so if
you stay at home between those
time periods you'll get your parcel and
then you can enjoy your day so you know
if you're at home
and the parcel doesn't come you're like
i've been waiting here for this parcel
it hasn't come and as soon as you leave
the house it turns up so
that has an even bigger impact on the
other parts of the business because the
the end uh recipients of parcels get
angry so just this act of
cleansing the data at the start had this
impact all the way through the process
and it affected every single team and
just getting together
and mapping all of that out with all of
the people in this nice room that smells
of wood very old wood
with a buddha in the corner watching us
well not in the corner in in the
fireplace
yeah it was nice it was just good to see
a lot of insights were happening
and then in the evening they allowed me
to stay and join them for
a nice dinner and wine tasting that was
pretty cool
and at one of the tables
so in the event storming session
um
one of the teams said yeah we've got
this problem we need to build an api
and one of the other teams said we've
already built an api that does that they
didn't even realize
two teams in the same company it's not
even a big company didn't even realize
that an api already existed for their
problem so at the dinner and the wine
tasting
they actually implemented that on the
same day
then storming in the day
fix the problem in the evening
getting together for collaboration
so
this to me that that day on that farm
with the lovely smelling wood
no that that to me is
a a sign of what it's like to be working
in a modern company these days the way
we build products the way software
developers and product people and all
these roles work together
and there's two things here um coming
this is coming from the product
management space now
so there's the surveys um it used to be
called alpha ux i think they change the
name now
but this is what product managers think
they think that the best ideas come from
the team brainstorming
um well that's the second best idea it's
very close to being the best idea and
that's what happens with event storming
you get your team together like if
you've read the domain during design
book it all feels very one-way it's like
the developers talk to the domain
experts and build a model but nowadays
it's like the whole team gets together
and the whole team is designing the
product together themselves
the boundaries between people who design
the product and people who implement it
that's becoming very blurry um martin
kagan's got a nice quote too
if you're only using engineers the code
you're getting like half their value
and if you've been to an event storming
session and you've seen developers and
tests and customer support people all
working together to figure out how can
we improve the product i think you would
definitely agree with that statement
i also think this um
this diagram john cutler's put together
emphasizes this kind of transition that
we're going through if you think about
the top pro waterfall back in the 90s
every team every step in the process of
building software was a separate team
with a handover you had the development
team who receive requirements hand over
to the testing team who test it
obviously there's a lot of stuff going
back here when things fail testing so it
wasn't always just one way but then over
the last
10 20 years
we've started we had this agile thing
when agile first started it was like oh
we'll have the developers and testers
sitting together to make it a bit
quicker then it became a bit more
oh let's get the developers up to you
know to own the testing themselves and
work closely with the testers in the
same team
um earning their releases you build it
you run it and then probably in the
2010s i think um
started to move the other way too we
started to bring design into the teams
you know and now we're in this phase
down here towards the bottom where
we're starting to
expect teams to build the products
themselves requirements don't come into
the teams it's more about hey here's
your north star as a team
figure out yourselves what you want to
build what work with business to define
your okrs
and so i use this diagram a lot when i'm
running workshops to to understand where
companies think they are and where they
want to get to
now we still have a lot of people quite
close to the top it's not like we're all
down here in this happy world of event
storming now to a lot of companies in
this model up here
but you can see that you know most
people do want to get to this part of
the bottom where the whole team is
responsible for the product so i think
that's where we're moving and that's why
concepts like event storming are really
useful for bringing the whole team
together
but on the
on the flip side of this
sometimes
sometimes uh
sometimes managers think it's it's an
easy thing to go from
from up here to down here when really so
it's incredibly difficult to go from
having silos and handovers to the team
owns everything
you know on one side here
you can't just change your teams to be
all empowered and autonomous because
your software architecture is designed
in is already aligned in a certain way
when i worked at salesforce in 2016
i can't i realized this i was quite
naive at the time like i was responsible
for the architecture and i was like well
however we shape our architecture
however we organize our domains
the way the teams are currently
structured means every team will touch
every code base you can't you can't
you can't really change software
architecture without changing the way
teams are structured
so that's part of this and then
it's not just about structure there's a
lot of leadership changes that need to
go through management of the company
you know going from up here to down here
it's such a
such a huge mindset change
um and here's a couple of examples so
um
i'm i'm not going to say much about this
company but it's kind of a
theme i see a lot it's like oh
no
people like to focus on structure we've
identified that our teams might be
organized in the wrong way
help us to find our value streams what
they should be
and we'll organize the teams around
those and everything's going to be great
right like yeah why is it taking so long
they expect this in like a couple of
days workshop
and it's not that simple
this was another example from 2017 a
german company
we had this two-day workshop to identify
all of their domains
and we had a good event storming session
actually i was pretty proud of it
um and then at the end they were like
okay let's talk about the teams now
and they said we've got a fish we've got
no not 50 year old it's 10 year old
we've got a 10 year old monolith c plus
plus with 50 000 business rules
everything's tightly coupled
and now we have this other slide where
it was like we're going to have all of
these independent teams with their
completely separate backlogs all working
independently like
never going to happen is it when you've
got a code base that coupled you can't
just suddenly have all these autonomous
empowered teams doing
that stuff on their own
so this is where the main german design
and team topologies start coming
together to try and
give us a picture of
what we can try and get to and how we
can get there too
so thinking back to john cutler's
diagram from a few slides ago those
different levels
that bottom level he's looking at we
need to have a structure like this both
the teams and the architecture so in
team topologies we have stream aligned
teams a team owns a value stream and a
value stream is
an area of the business or a domain that
the team is responsible for the team
works in that area to identify new
opportunities for the business
and then that team is responsible for
building the capabilities that they need
to
address the problems they've found
themselves in that domain they own the
software to do that
and they're responsible for delivering
it to customers assessing it monitoring
it in the market and stuff so that
that's really the structure
of a value stream in that bottom row
we've got the team aspect the domain
aspect and the software aspect
and so in this talk today
i'm going to show you how you can use
these different techniques event
storming team topologies and the major
and design to go through this process of
identifying your domain boundaries your
value streams
and
then
looking at teams apologies concepts to
work out are they good boundaries um
looking at some of the team aspects we
talked about around ownership coupling
and autonomy
and then we'll look at some concepts
from domain driven design called core
domains
which is about helping you focus on
where should we start first because
don't want to give you this idea that
it's kind of like
you have an event storming workshop you
find all your domains and then
you go home on friday and you come back
on monday and you do a big real it's
it's much more gradual than that so i'm
going to try and get across of that in
this part here it's going to have a
quick drink
so if you haven't heard of event
storming before
kind of
emphasizing here what i was alluding to
earlier it's great because
you bring people together from different
parts of the business and different
skills
and you can start to see everything
together
like i talked about in the workshop in
germany we had those two developers in
different teams
who realized oh you've built an api for
that we could use we didn't realize that
and we also have the customer success
people and the product people
bringing their insights
contrasting we've got the developers
sort of things so
it's like vertical horizontal a lot of
sharing knowledge
and if you want to find good domain
boundaries i think this is key really to
get all those insights together
in one place
otherwise
you know traditionally this is often
been done by architects working to the
side but this is based on all of their
assumptions whereas with event storming
it's much more democratized bringing
more people's insights into the process
so we can make uh more sensible
decisions
if you haven't seen event storming it's
it's kind of simple really if you're
expecting something big and exciting and
amazing it's just orange post it's in a
timeline
um
that's it
how can i speak for like 50 minutes
about orange post it's in a timeline
i'll just give you a quick example
though so
these these events are in past tense
order dropped off
10 reward points added to driver's
profile delivery received food eaten
five-star review left and we can see
there's two different flows there the
simplicity is really what makes it
accessible to a wide group it's a low
fidelity technique which means there's
no learning curve and you can get a
bunch of people together who've never
done it before like we did in germany
and you can actually map out the whole
business together so that's why it's
cool
once you've mapped out an event storm it
then becomes
it then becomes a map or a landscape and
you can start doing lots of interesting
things with it firstly
uh in this example
you can start identifying problems and
hot spots
the great thing about this is
you know someone might
indicate there's a problem and someone
else might say oh i never knew about
that kind of like the api situation oh
i never knew you had that problem we've
got an api for you here it is we'll fix
it in the wine tasting later
um what else you got on here yeah so you
can kind of you can map out all kinds of
problems on an event storm
technical errors whether companies
losing money what else have we got
yeah where people disagree about things
you know often we have
um people who
think parts of a business process work
in different ways someone says no no the
process works this way someone else says
no no it works that way with event
storming we can highlight those
inconsistencies and we can validate that
after the workshop
on the other side of things we can also
identify opportunities
things like target new customers that's
why it's always good to be specific in
your event storming sessions if you just
talk about a customer
you're losing some insights there if you
talk about like a gold customer or a
silver customer you can then start
saying oh how could we change his
process how would it be different what
would we need to do differently in our
product to support someone who's not a
silver customer what about
what about if we wanted to have like a
bronze customer so being specific
starts to open up all of these
opportunities and to be honest thing
about event storming is
when you've got all these orange
post-its and timeline on the timeline
just laid out
it's like so hard to not think of
problems and opportunities there it's
like it's just
you just you just start to see things oh
what if we did that differently what if
we did those two things in a different
order it's just
my mind goes crazy when i see an event
storm like all these things just jumping
out of me and i think it's probably the
same for everyone just such a great
technique
so
once you've mapped out your business
with event storming that's when we get
in to start identifying boundaries now
these boundaries will become our team
boundaries and software boundaries
so we have this concept called a pivotal
event
um it's a simple concept but i sometimes
struggle to explain it so
i'll try and i'll try and start with
this simple definition first
i would say the simple way of looking
for a pivotal event
is where one sub-process ends
or another one starts
it's not always clear where something
starts and stops
but generally if you if you look for
that you'll
end up in the right places so we've got
this example here
and i've highlighted membership
requested as a pivotal event
and this is because
it feels like
this
part here
is the member or the candidate the
non-member requesting
they've they've that feels to me
separate like they've requested this
membership
for them that that part of the process
is done and now we're triggering two
separate process processes the
anti-fraud checks
and the onboarding assessment you know
so you could say that's all one process
but to me that looks like a
scene between different sub processes
and there's a couple of other clues on
here
um
i would probably pick out
the handover as a good one whenever you
see
so these events here are the non-member
but now we've got a fraud checker and an
account manager involved so that hand
over between different roles
is also another sign you're at the edge
of a process
we can also see like it's not actually
on here but
over here we call the person a
non-member but after this membership
requested pivotal events we now refer to
them as a pending member so that actors
role how we refer to them has changed so
yeah all these signs are pointing
towards
that's the
that's a boundary between different
things
another thing i always recommend looking
for is these domain roles if anyone came
to the workshop yesterday morning we've
already talked about this
but basically
different parts of your business
serve
different generic uh generic roles let's
say
so campaign builder this is this is
from an advertising industry
campaign builder is about describing the
advertising campaign you want to run
it's all about collecting all the
information making the choices
creating the specification of what to do
then
the next domain campaign runner
is taking that specification and running
that campaign for you so
that often that split between describe
and do
is is a good candidate for boundaries
and then optimize at the end
this is this is characterized by
taking lots of information from
different places harvesting that and
generating some insights from that like
oh in this example
um you're never getting any impressions
between 6 a.m and 10 a.m in the morning
why don't you just
not run your campaign during those hours
and try different hours instead that
kind of stuff so again these are more
clues about the boundaries
so once you've got an event storm
you can start applying all of these
clues looking for pivotal events you can
start shaping into different domains
this is an example of a remote session
you know it's very similar in in-person
or remote
try and try and slice it up there are
some great advantages to remote though
um you can copy and paste the event
storm have different groups exploring
different possibilities really find that
aspect and promote interesting
and here's an example of something which
sometimes i think sometimes event
storming can lead you slightly in the
wrong direction because it's a timeline
it biases you towards grouping things
which are together in the timeline but
this is an important distinction between
like a user journey and a domain so in
this example here we've got the
onboarding process
these are some steps a user goes through
from not being a user to actually being
in the system and able to use the
company's products and services so we
call that phase the onboarding
but if you look at this
this this user journey is actually using
different capabilities
so
adding personal information
uploading a driving license
adding some funds to your accounts
yeah those capabilities are very
different we probably wouldn't want to
have those in the same code base you
know that they're very separate even
though they're brought together as part
of this process so
that's one thing to look out for with
event storming try not to confuse too
much that the journeys and the domains
however very often you will have a
domain which is
a sequence of events in the timeline so
yeah it's just those subtleties to look
for
right so what i'm going to talk about
now is how you can how you can go from
event storming towards software
architecture and your team boundaries
now i would definitely say
event stormings
it's not going to get you all the way
there
what what comes out of an event storming
session to me is what i would call a
candidate value stream or candidate
domain boundaries now it's still quite
high level we need to get more into the
details and validate those further and
that's where team topologies can help
if you've not heard of team topologies
before
a very quick um definition here
it's basically a bunch of principles and
patterns
for
for establishing teams in the model of
john cutler we spoke about earlier that
those bottom rows in the process where
we have autonomous teams who design the
product who build the products you
support in production you build it you
run it it's about principles and ideas
to achieve that and this book has been
really good
at getting management and and leaders
to
understand these concepts and it's
actually
you know if you're if you're a developer
and you you know if you find sometimes
management leadership in your company
doesn't really get some of the technical
concepts
this book is doing a lot to change the
the management perspective in our
industry
um
i've been a lot of zoom calls
where people just like have a copy of
this book it's also it's almost become
like a meme now
like have you read team's apologies like
yeah i have it and i'm like well i've
got a signed copy so
um
so where are we going with that yeah so
i think it's also you know useful for
developers to be able to understand
these concepts too
be able to talk with your business get
these ideas into your company
i think one of the best ways to actually
start applying team topologies is to
look at the independent service
heuristics they've created on github
list of questions and checks it's
nothing too complicated but if you've
identified some potential domain
boundaries or architecture boundaries or
team boundaries you can go through this
list and start assessing that like will
this work are we are we ready
to
commit to these candidate boundaries
so the first one
is around the concept of cognitive load
i would say in my experience
yeah most teams are overloaded right
everyone's like
urgent deadlines lots of work
don't have time to go slowly think
properly add quality
and so team topologies
have been making this essential concept
in the book
trying to help management and leaders
understand
you need to stop putting so much load
into your teams you're just overworking
your teams and that's causing you to
have like unmaintainable software
so
um in order to explain that there's a
couple of
teen topologies has basically been quite
opinionated about what a team is to try
and emphasize this so
they're saying that a team a good team
is five to nine people
in my experience i would strongly agree
with that i think
when i've been in a team with more than
nine people
you do start to get a lot of
distractions it's hard to keep up with
all the people in your team so i'm quite
on board with this i would have been
happy with that anyway
and there's also some research which is
about
the more people in a team
the harder it is to build a higher level
of trust with that many people so five
to nine there is some research behind
that
and so
that's basically the upper limit you've
got to identify
you basically the maximum size domain
you can have in your event storm
or after your event storming session is
something that can be managed by five to
a team of five to nine people if it's
too much work if there's too much work
going on in that domain then it's too
big and this first check here would stop
us doing that
sometimes i see incredible things
and this was incredible
i was working with one company
and there was a team of three developers
they were working on the company's
oldest legacy like
i'm like wow that's that's a pretty
tough gig like you've don't have many
people like you've got to do all the new
business work coming in
and you got to try and refactor and
clean this old system up that's
that's crazy and then we got to the best
bit i'm like they kept talking about
yeah you know we don't know who to
please we've got a lot of people asking
us to do work so i'm like can you can
you tell me who these people are can we
just discuss
all the sources of work
and they legitimately had 10 different
stakeholders who all wanted them to
build stuff
in that year
if that is not cognitive overload
i do not know what is
that's just crazy so that's what we're
trying to avoid here
it is okay
for a team to own multiple domains if
they're smaller and less complex or
maybe one larger domain so there is some
trade-offs here and in a lot of
companies you do have a lot of small
systems you don't have enough teams to
have one team per domain so there are
some trade-offs to be made here but
you should never get to this situation
right so the second heuristic there's
there's 10 heuristics on that page
this is another one i picked out
around the independent aspect so we
looked at john cutler's diagram earlier
and this heuristic is saying is the
organization prepared so that this team
can own an area of the domain
identify opportunities themselves and
implement these things themselves
so in team topologies they talk about
these different interaction modes as a
way to
as a way to identify if a team has too
many dependencies of the wrong type the
first type
is collaboration
this is basically a situation where two
teams are working together usually with
some shared goals like i'm building some
stuff in my code base
max is building some stuff in his code
base and collectively
those things will come together as part
of some some new feature we have a
collaboration we have stand-ups together
we have meetings together we do planning
together we go for lunch together
although not anymore
um so that you know collaboration is
quite a high high trust
if i can't add cognitive load there to
your team some of your time is taken up
collaborating with other teams
x as a surface on the other hand
is where
my team maybe uses max's api
but
i don't have to collaborate with him to
do that i read his docs i send him a
couple of messages on slack and i can
start using it kind of like when you use
aws and cloud stuff
and then facilitating is where one team
is spending some time helping another
team like coaching or
if my team's
late we've got a big deadline coming up
maybe max will help us to achieve that
deadline
so the key thing is when you start to
map these out you can start to identify
problems
so in this example here
you can see that all of the cloud all of
the collaboration with all of the
interactions between the teams is
collaboration
there's no extras of service in this
company anywhere and that's adding a
high cognitive load
um there were there was a lot of
talk around the integration platform
that this team
was always a bottleneck for things when
we spoke to this team
it turned out that this integration
platform team
were
they were building stuff for those other
teams so they'd gone from being a
platform to actually
kind of like doing bits of code for
those other teams and maintaining stuff
for them and that's very easy to happen
with a platform
with a platform you really want to have
an x as a service that teams can use the
platform you don't want to have the
platform team owning bits of these other
teams
i found it quite surprising really that
you know when we mapped this out and saw
this
no one had really connected those dots
before so it's a useful exercise just to
try this
to map out your teams and the
interaction modes
and as a quick sense check do you have
too much collaboration going on
all right so the third one is around
team ownership so
if you want to get to the bottom couple
of rows in john cutler's diagram then
the team needs to own their own road map
be able to make their own decisions
not people outside the team telling them
what they're going to work on what their
deadlines are
and here's an example of where that
didn't work out
so there was the healthcare platform
team
and there were the healthcare platform
verticals
one of the verticals was
basically
yeah one of the verticals was quite old
10 years the other two were a bit newer
one of them was a new idea coming to
market
and so this platform team
they had a lot of ideas like how can we
take this concept that we've been this
domain that we've owned
for one vertical and how can we make
that more generic so it works for all
three of these verticals
we don't want to have a bunch of if-else
statements in our code if this vertical
do this if that vertical do that because
then we'll just have lots of coupling
but we also we want to help these
verticals to be able to focus on their
problems and not this core platform
issue that's outside of them we also
want the ability to spin up new
verticals in the future quickly and this
platform could be a major enabler of
that so they they need to figure out
this difficult problem how can we build
something abstract for these different
verticals
but the problem was
they weren't able to do what they
thought was right because they didn't
have a budget
basically all of their budget came from
those verticals the vertical team would
say
we need you to build this feature for us
and we'll pay you this amount of money
to keep your team running to build it
and then another vertical would say
we need you to build this feature for us
and we'll pay you this amount of money
you can
to to your team to build that so
this team was like
no autonomy to own their road map
all they could do is
what the verticals were telling them to
do and it had to be exactly what the
vertical needed
if the platform team wanted to build a
feature
and
it was more future based or refactor
something and no vertical wanted it
right now
there's no budget for that so it was all
very short-term driven
and i would say if you're looking at
teams apologies and autonomous teams
and you've got this model it's just not
going to work that team doesn't have the
autonomy to do what's right for the
company
to invest in quality into their platform
you know it's all very short term driven
by those verticals who who control them
like do what we say well you don't get
the money
it's got no choice
and i also see this the other way
actually where
companies do have the right kind of
leadership in place but then when they
move to these autonomous teams the teams
themselves aren't ready i was in this
one uh meeting a community of practice
in 20
2020 i think it was
told you that timelines are all blurry
since the pandemic thing so
basically the company had gone from
projects to products they'd gone from
like a fixed scope time and budget to
teams who are responsible for certain
areas they were implementing team
topologies and i was in the community of
practice
and one of the platform owners he said
yeah i'm struggling after we've gone
from project to product in this new
world
i don't know i don't know what to work
on we're not getting enough feedback
from the business stakeholders i said to
him
he said i got an email recently
i just couldn't do anything with it and
i said can you show us the email
so he showed us the email
and that
vp
she said to him
i think these initiatives might be
things to focus on but
i'm gonna let you decide
i was like that's great
she's saying you can decide your team is
empowered to build what you think is
right you tell her what you're gonna do
if she disagrees she'll let you know
otherwise keep going just keep doing
stuff and if she's not happy she'll let
you know but he's like he's been so used
to working in his project mindset of
having scope fixed following this plan
for months he wasn't ready for it so now
this concept of autonomous teams is
difficult to get there from both
perspectives a leadership needs to put
in place the funding model giving teams
empowerment but the teams themselves
need to be able to deal with that too
very very difficult issue
so
if you go through the team's apologies
independent service heuristics there's a
whole bunch of them you can think about
all these different aspects
and once you've done that you'll get to
a point where you're like okay we
identified these domain boundaries
we've applied all of these team
topologies checks yeah and we think it's
good we think we've
got to a good place now we're happy with
them but it's not going to be a case of
you go home on friday and then you come
back on monday and do the big re-org it
takes time to make these changes um
and it needs to be done step by step i
did work with one company i went home on
wednesday i had two days off and on the
monday they'd gone from project to
product but there was a reason for that
um doesn't i wouldn't normally recommend
that
so we have this concept in domain driven
design of core supporting and generic
and this helps us to look at those
domains we identify during event
storming and understand you know which
parts of the business are the most
important if we're going to set up
um these autonomous teams to start
reshaping our architecture
where's the most important place to
start
you know we don't want to start this
initiative
and
we pick a complex area of the system and
the business are saying well you know
you're going to spend six months on that
but we don't see any value there so this
tool can help you to focus on the
domains that are most important and
start
identifying the right areas
with this kind of core domain shot you
can also analyze how things are changing
over time
so usually if something's moving up and
to the right
it's getting more complex because you're
solving a harder problem that's a good
kind of complexity whereas
if something's more to the left and the
arrows going down
usually you're trying to indicate this
thing has become overly complex it's
expensive to run and maintain we want to
reduce that complexity so by mapping all
these things out you can start seeing
your options about where you start
applying team topologies where you start
refactoring your architecture
you can have these conversations with
your products and business stakeholders
and you can agree on exactly where to
focus
the y-axis is how complex is it as an
engineer that's that's your decision to
say how hard it's going to be
[Music]
to exploit the opportunities in that
domain whereas the x-axis is the
business saying
this is how important it is to us to
exploit opportunities in that domain and
so with this diagram you can you can
have an agreement on that and then
decide
what's the best cost benefit
so i've got an example here from a
company in the experiences industry
this company was really interesting
they own like a small part of the value
chain um
if i say what it is it might give them
away too much it's basically like um
selling selling tickets and then they
decided we're gonna like do the whole
thing we're going to like organize all
the events um
hotels flights accommodation celebrities
all this kind of stuff
but they noticed
they had this um
they had like 100 they had not 100 page
it was about a 20-page document with
like 100 problems they've got and we use
the core domain chart to start assessing
where they should focus
and we identified this one problem
it was basically
it started building these different
systems up over time
and
when they were making certain changes
certain kinds of changes to the product
they noticed oh
we have to change these four systems
together there's a lot of coupling there
and what had happened is
this there was a domain i didn't realize
was a domain and the bits of that domain
lived in those different systems and
this was causing all of the couplings
you had a bunch of teams all working in
the same code bases tripping over each
other
and they also had this crazy manual
process involved 30 people and excel
spreadsheets
um probably some other manual stuff in
there as well
and that was another symptom of this and
the solution was really
um if you can
extract those pieces and put them
together you'll reduce that coupling and
you can solve that manual process which
involves
getting data out of that system into
that system into that system so
consolidating that domain
will be a good and this will also be
good
this will also be a good candidate for
setting up their first team they
currently had a project mindset as well
so using the core domain chart we were
able to have this conversation
the business were more focused on their
core domains
they wanted to exploit those two domains
in the right hand corner with some new
features and new capabilities
but with this chart we were able to
explain to them actually
if we can consolidate that hidden domain
and make that we can get rid of that
manual process
we can make those changes easier
actually
when that system is simpler
it will be easier to make those changes
in your core domain because those core
domains actually depend on that
supporting domain so this was how we
were able to explain that actually
investing in fixing the current system
first
would actually be better in the long
term for adding those new capabilities
they wanted in the core domains
so there's a couple of patterns i think
which help to understand this concept
two seconds
so yeah when you're going through this
process of trying to identify
where do we focus first where do we set
up teams apologies
there are these different patterns that
can give you clues about
short-term versus long-term benefits
this one in the top right hand corner is
what i call a decisive core
it's different very differentiating and
very complex
and therefore you know as a software
engineer
any effort we apply here will be
beneficial building quality in this part
of the system will have an impact in the
long term because it's hard for
competitors to copy
if you're talking about events storming
and getting people together
these are the kind of complex part of
your business where it makes sense to
really do that whereas on the other hand
you've got this kind of indefensible
core domain i see a lot of domain design
people making this mistake where
something's important
and they think it's a core domain and it
is but because it's a bit less complex
it means your competitors will be easily
able to copy this over time and so in
one year from now it won't be your core
domain anymore so as an engineer
a bit less quality is needed here it's a
shorter term objective i had one company
recently an american company from texas
who do payments
and basically we did a session like this
and they said
all of our domains go from core to
supporting in one year it's very hard in
this industry to
to actually get a competitive advantage
and keep it just nothing nothing stays
around that long and that's the kind of
thing you want to get from these
sessions to understand in a company like
that
you can't really focus on one thing and
just do that well it's like we've got to
have a constant stream of new things
coming along and that totally changes
your mindsets about what you focus
i also think one of the problems that
germany and design people make as well
is
whenever they talk about core domains
they're talking about
what makes money now but actually it's
also about what makes money in the
future
something that's not making money now
might make 90 of your revenue in just a
few years from now so it's also worth
working with your stakeholders and your
teams and looking at
what's not here at the moment or what
are we looking at that could be a core
domain in the future what's a new thing
what's a disruptive thing we're working
on i worked on a project once i was in
that team
a lot of things happen when i take a day
off i took a couple of days off and when
i came back
like some people from my team had been
taken away like
what's going on guys we've got this
major project that you said like the big
future trying to get this thing running
on the cloud and you're currently on
prem and it's like oh this other team
over here have taken some people because
they've got an urgent deadline
i i spoke to that team and they're like
well you know this is the product that
makes the money so
we get to take your people when we need
to
but no that's a totally wrong mindset
you're taking away from your future self
just to hit some short term deadline
you know solving that in six months
could be much more beneficial than
solving some immediate problem in the
next two months so again with the core
domain charts we want to try and get
these things out talking about what's
what's coming on here that's not on
there now whenever you see things moving
from the right to the left
you always need to worry what's going to
replace it what's going to be the
coordinate in a few months from now
and then also i find a lot of the
supporting patterns can be interesting
um
in this example you've got a supporting
domain
which is depended on by lots of core
domains and this this in itself is
almost a core domain right a domain
driven design person might say oh that's
a supporting domain therefore it's not
that important but actually if you look
at this
keeping that supporting domain
modular clean easy to change it's going
to make it easier for your core domain
to change so it is still very important
just because it's supporting doesn't
mean it's not that important so yeah
with this tool
we can bring out a lot of nuance into
these conversations and make sure we're
applying the right mindset
and then there's this other one the
suspect supporting had a great example
of this one um people thought this was
their core domain it was a company in
turkey a couple of years ago and all the
engineers said oh this order management
system
is our core domain and we're like why is
it your core domain why is it over here
how does it differentiate your company
and they're like well it doesn't really
differentiate us it's just everyone's
talking about it it's the most important
project right now
ah well let's dig into that a bit more
and basically they were building a new
order management system
but they still had their old order
management system and they had to
synchronize the data and the users had
to use both systems because the new
system didn't have all the features of
the old system yet
so okay it's it's become a bit of a
problem in the company
people are talking about this a lot but
it's not it's not really the core domain
people have thought
people are talking about this the most
therefore it must be the core domain but
it wasn't and we realized it was
actually just way over here just very
complex and it was important to get that
complexity down because it was sucking a
lot of people to work on that
right the final thing is what we call
the modernization core domain charts
this is a great tool i use when
when thinking about where where do we
start specifically
especially when you're thinking about
we'd like to try team topologies and the
management design where do we start
this can help you identify a good
opportunity balancing both the business
aspects the technical aspects and the
team aspects so ideally we want to pick
something in the bottom right hand
corner
the low-hanging fruit
i would say this is a kind of project
where
if some company wants to try something
new around how teams are set up and how
they
maybe if they want to move to the cloud
and try that
if you can build a new product
that has immediate value to the business
something new that's a good low hanging
fruit
in the top left hand corner we've got
the opposite something which is going to
be very difficult to modernize and put
autonomous teams around it and there's
not much value of doing so so we can
leave those to the end
and then we've got the difficult
trade-off
in the bottom left-hand corner
you're picking something simpler
but there's less value
let's say you're a company who's on a
monolith to microservices journey
you might say oh there's a bit of the
monolith we can extract out into a
separate microservice
it's not that valuable to the business
but there is some value if we take it
out of the monolith we can add new
features a bit faster so
but it allows us to experiment with new
tech and the ways of working
whereas the top right hand corner
is something where if you can extract
this from the monolith you're going to
get a huge payback
however it's very difficult to get out
of the monolith you know it's like
there's a god object it's coupled to
like 14 other things it's coupled to all
the database tables it's going to take
you six months to extract it so
yeah when you're looking to apply these
concepts and think about where we start
i think this kind of tool can be useful
to balance the business versus the
technical side of things as all in my
experience there's always that the
engineers
we always want to pick something which
allows us to validate the technical
choices and the ways of working we're
trying to establish
but then we have to explain to the
business actually
you're not going to get anything out of
that in the short term it's just for us
whereas the other scale of thing is
the business might say oh
we've got this big requirement if you
start there
then
you'll be able to validate your new
technology choices
and we'll get something out of it but
the problem is because it's so complex
it might take much longer than you
thought you know i pick one company
going on this monolith to microservices
from on-prem to the cloud
they picked one of those
they were willing to take some risk in
the top right hand corner they picked a
project that had to be done in six
months
one year later they didn't even have one
line of code in the cloud they had so
much compliance and security to deal
with he just didn't get one line of code
to the cloud so if you do take a risk up
there
now
you've got the
business people watching you and they're
expecting something out of this so
yeah it's always difficult choosing
where to start
um i didn't really talk much about how
you measure the value on those different
axes you can check out a lot of
information on this github page we've
put some ideas also a great blog post
here helps you to measure how how
complex different parts of your system
are
so that's basically it it's going to
wrap up with a few things
i think firstly um i want to try and get
to a situation where we can avoid big
re-orgs and
big rewrites and just have
organizations where
it's
it's more of a concert and gradual thing
and that's why i think it's important
for teams themselves to understand the
mainstream design and team topologies
and a team can identify hey
we've got too much collaboration with
other teams here we need to have an
extra service relationship
you know if the teams identify that when
it's happening
you're going to get assigned much
earlier in the process
and avoid that data integration platform
where that team ends up owning a bunch
of stuff they shouldn't and it's going
to be hard to undo that
as an example here if you want to
practice this we've created a miro board
there's an example of event storm laid
out
and you can slice up that event storm
into domains you can practice with core
domain charts
totally free to use there's no
advertising or anything
and there's some other tools here we
didn't talk about we've got
message flow modeling
bounded context canvas
context mapping these are other
techniques from domain driven design
you can read about them and see some
examples and try it all out for free
there's this data modeling process we
got a bit bored during the pandemic and
we were like
what can what can we do why don't we try
and make it easier for people to learn
and apply domain during design and so we
came up with this this is the
um not the first iteration but it's
where we've got to now
we don't recommend this as a best
practice
but if you're like how do i get started
with ddd in my company how do i bring
these concepts in now it helps you to go
through the process once or twice see
these different techniques how they fit
together and then from there you can
start
going freestyle
and so very final slides
two things i would recommend you to do
after this talk
the first one is to read team topologies
bring these ideas into your company i
think that could only be a good thing
and the second one is
if you haven't done event storming
before uh run your first workshop
see if you get to see if you uncover
some interesting things try and bring a
nice diverse group together
the yoga room with the wood smell is
completely optional but definitely
recommend it if you like the smell of
old wood
you can replace that with your own
preferred smells if you like and that's
it thank you for coming
[Applause]
you